tu as quel âge Maëva 25 ans 25 ans ça
fait combien de temps que tu fais la
télé-réalité 5 ans ça fait 5 ans que tu
es connu seulement que j'ai l'impression
que ça fait 20 ans
par les marchés en Australie comment tu
as été contacté
Facebook à l'époque c'était comme ça les
castings il m'avait envoyé un message
sur facebook pour passer le casting et
j'ai passé sur facebook tu mets tes
photos tu mettais des trucs
c'est toi c'était ce que tu voulais
faire dans la vie à 20 ans tu t'es dit
tu faisais quoi
et non c'était pas du tout prévu genre
ça m'est tombé dessus comme ça
les Marseillais en Australie et là tu
t'es dit c'est la vie que je veux avoir
en vacances avec tes amis tu es payé tu
es payé c'est trop bien tu étais reconnu
et connu donc tu t'es dit c'est le
métier que je veux faire
gagner beaucoup de sous après est-ce que
tu es devenu une star
des défis les plus connus de la
télé-réalité Maeva donc tu t'es dit
voilà c'est c'est incroyable ce qui
c'est une mission de dressing sur 6play
ah oui ça je sais et tu peux aussi des
dressing
des personnes de dressing